foreign
[Music]
thank you
music box
[Music]
I guess that's called pacing myself
because it's got a lot to do today I've
got two shows that I will be doing today
and so will uh one of the gentlemen or
this is foreshadowing a lot to get to I
don't know if you saw this Tucker
Carlson now there have been leaked
videos leaked texts oh this is all
happenstance right this happened with
James O'Keefe it's uh now happened with
Tucker Carlson it's happened with one of
the men here in studio it's uh it just
happens all at once when the big boys
leave the uh the former Big League soon
to be minor league so I want to hear uh
what your thoughts are and if you think
that what Tucker did was that bad I
think you need a little bit of
perspective I think go with me now it
was funny so we're going to show these
videos
there's also uh the story now 1500
soldiers are being deployed to the
border and somebody saying hey maybe
that's a good thing well hold on a
second we're going to give you a then
and now with this Administration how
they've done an about face also how
they've altered the numbers which I
think you should know border crossings
are up not down despite what that uh the
pirate press secretary says also
[Music]
foreign
definitely and we'll also be talking
about the recent book Banning agenda
that you're seeing from the left there's
so much to get to this is there really
is this Tempest right now yeah that you
are seeing with some people uh in the uh
in the crosshairs and Tucker is is right
there and uh you know I I hope the guy
lands on his feet and does well but
first before we move on well not first I
just did what was first but uh Gerald a
CEO how are you sir I'm doing well how
are you I'm good yeah yeah how do I
thought the pedal thing you were like
well that's my guy it was great I mean
he's doing the right things I've been uh
yeah I had a good morning I uh when
feeling little ones I come up with new
songs all the time I didn't want to eat
how did this happen well so I was saying
uh I'm about to feed bananas to you so
get ready and get ready
I think I may get some strawberries too
so get ready get I'm about to feed you
so here it comes and then how did that
work well one did not like it at all and
the other was just going but didn't eat
this it was just mashed bananas
everything yeah
well at least you had funds failing yeah
exactly
what I'm good at so my skill set is
largely useless but it works well with
children and in third share you hear
this
you know who it is he is the OG and of
course you cannot watch him at all later
today and I will not be on his show
later today at mad maxworld.tv it's not
a thing it doesn't exist he doesn't
still exist and you cannot watch it mad
maxworld.tv Mr Alex Jones how are you
sir it is good to be here and I really
can't wait to talk about the Border
can't wait to talk about Tucker Carlson
but also just a few hours ago two drones
crashed into the Kremlin residence of
Vladimir Putin almost killing him and
they're threatening to escalate to
nuclear war as Ukraine launches a
massive offensive and threatened to
invade Russia itself I asked how you
were doing but that's well that's how
I'm doing and I and again you are not
coming on my show at 11 A.M no Central
today I didn't even know you had a show
I don't even have that up that website
we cannot say Do not you're not going to
be co-hosting from your studio it's just
fun to say yeah it's just a fun word to
say Mad maxwell.tv Mad Max world.tv if
you say it three times fast it's hard
but it's fun to say even though that
takes you to the video side that has the
evil that doesn't happen it doesn't show
the knots and by the way if you signed
up understand we've heard you if you
have not received if you signed up a
while ago didn't receive your mug or
signed up and are it's a tough time
financially for a lot of you right
signing up here uh now of course as we
partner with Rumble mug Club you send in
your proof of purchase to any
conservative streaming service just send
in a screenshot at freemud Club louder
with credit.com yeah you get three
months free but anyway
conservative streaming service free mug
club atlanta.com boom we take care of
you and by the way I don't know if some
of your subscribers will do that but of
course we'll uh we'll work I mean
hopefully they watch all of it at
everything over at Infowars is is free
to Air uh but we are planning to also do
a subscription situation down the road
to be able to fund the bigger
infrastructure more shows the exact
thing you're doing because as you said
yeah the old dinosaur media isn't dying
it's dead we are the new media and
that's why everybody's coming after you
because you are number one on Rumble and
uh right up there at the top on YouTube
and so that is a mark of success and it
doesn't happen until the system's scared
of you Alex maybe there's some Synergy
there who knows you know subscriptions
and subscriptions I'm sure a lot of
people they they like your show that
doesn't exist
and you know we may or may not like we
like each other we do I like Alex Alex
I always tell people and look can I just
defend you for once I love you so much
this morning
well come on that's not a novelty you're
a little upset about it but that is
every morning
even when we're not in the same state
but remember when people attacked you
and said oh Alex Jones a performance
artist so that was part of the case
everyone here we talked about this show
of hands who can confirm that Alex Jones
is exactly what you expect him to be off
air it's just one of those things that
the media ran with of course because if
they try and take away your credibility
then people think oh he must be faking
it matter of fact if anything you might
want to scale it back a little bit
because you know I don't know if your
heart can take it well I've offered
people a million dollars if they can
find where I sit on the stand that I
don't believe what I'm saying and I'm an
actor what they were doing in a custody
battle now six years ago was they wanted
to enter into the case in front of the
jury me playing a part of a joker saying
kids use drugs it's great they'll kill
you so I was saying so kids wouldn't use
drugs right and my ex was trying to
introduce saying look he's he's crazy
he's the Joker and he's saying use drugs
and my lawyer gets up and says when Jack
Nicholson plays the part of the Joker in
Batman he's not literally that he's
being an actor here but as if my
listeners I mean I don't do as many
great skits as you do I used to do a lot
more of them but when I would do
schedule it's obvious when I'm dressed
up by cover Commander I'm not really the
leader of Cobra it doesn't exist like
reverse psychology only instead of like
oh oh liver is gross you were like do
LSD exactly well when Cobra Commander
would be like I support Obama and what
he's been doing it's good to the
radical Islamic should destabilize the
planet that's a pretty good Cobra
Commander so yeah and it's it's
obviously I'm not Cobra Commander so 95
of the time I'm being serious they want
to screw around the media always is like
about two years ago went super viral
there's millions of years I went on air
and I said everybody knows about the
famous essay 300 years ago about a
modest proposal by Swift where he was
Irish and they were letting the Irish
starve to death and didn't care about
the famine he said well why don't we
just have the Irish raise their babies
and sell them to English Lords and
Ladies as a new dish let's eat the
children now it's the most famous satire
ever yeah I said so here's my satire
everything collapses to keep the
lockdowns going where cannibalism will
kick in and I'm going to eat my liberal
neighbors yeah think about hauling up
with a chain well they just cut off me
saying this is a joke yes and said Jones
is not a total psychotic break and it's
so obvious you wouldn't eat your liberal
neighbor is too stringy now exactly live
show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern that's right Friday as well only
on most Club Monday through Friday 10
a.m Eastern and uh before well let's
just go on to this so uh Tick Tock you
know has these famous kids and this is
from the Tim Dillon show by the way
shout out to Tim the fact that they
issued this response in real time is
what I love yeah it got brass balls so I
appreciate it there are these gen Z kids
uh Chris Mowry and what's the other
guy's name Chris Mowry and Harry Harry
this is Samsonite and they've
they've kept going viral for all the
wrong reasons but here's a look at them
and then a recent appearance on Tim
Dillon's podcast which is worth the
watch because it's more of this yeah
what the Republican party doesn't
understand gen Z is we don't like you if
they think they can give the middle
finger to our generation and get away
with it they're sorely mistaken I'm
right in 2024 the choice for the 2024
presidential election is already clear
we have President Biden who's a good man
he's passed historic policy and he cares
about the American people but what do
the Republicans have Donald Trump and I
really want to be that person Rebels
without a pack because Democrats I mean
they're horrible at their jobs right
they do a lot of shitty things although
I'll vote for them all the time can we
clip that quote they're horrible please
don't please don't please don't clip it
please
yeah Rebellion is so last year let's
let's let's be the man let's be let's
just let's support the man let's join a
pack Isn't that cool kids
Conformity rocks yeah let's get the DJ
with Mouse ears let's check the justice
department on our political enemies yes
yes
man that's really radical rad man
Iron Fist of the state crushing
opposition
so rage for the machine yes I like it
too they already did reach for the
machine they supported a socialist
regime for credit everything about Rage
Against the Machine aside from some of
their music is crappy okay Tucker
Carlson and I know you've been in
support of Tucker Carlson so this is he
is you know he has a lot of uh of uh I
should say a lot of bows trained on him
right now he's had a few arrows in his
back uh and this has been going on with
a lot of people we've talked about uh
recently so since the exit at Fox it's
been escalating and I'm curious to see
what you guys have to say we'll take
some of your chats later but you can
comment below uh hit like on the show if
you uh if you do support actually Tucker
Carlson leaving there have been a number
now behind the scenes videos of Tucker
Carlson and they've mysteriously leaked
this is not a tactic that is
consistently seriously huh like this one
which is supposed to horrify you I
should preface this uh about
Gerald smiling because he knows exactly
the kinds of conversations that we've
had
Fox Nation look he's basically Hitler
bearing on the nighttime show and I want
it to look official I don't want it to
be like bro talk and I and I
you know what I mean
but nobody's going to watch it on Fox
Nation nobody watches Fox Nation because
the site sucks you don't say they like
to just put the dump the whole thing on
YouTube Lifetime movies but they don't
they don't work on the infrastructure of
the site like what it's crazy and it
drives me crazy because it's like we're
doing all this extra work and no one can
find it it's unbelievable actually I
don't know who runs that site
how dare him complaining what quality
for his subscribers I know how dare him
want it to Not Crash I know how dare it
he want the show to work this guy is the
biggest a-hole ever it's Himmler exactly
it's Himmler that's always what I've
said you complain about YouTube
experience was obsessed with a custom
consumer experience by the way yes how
do you cross Tucker with Hitler that's
the new word tuckler or what would it be
tuckler Hitler yes I'm Hitler still
Hitler still Hitler yes I do remember no
but look hey and the difference is Fox
Nation had no cares about fixing the
experience it's fine if you're working
on an experience but it's not when
you're just like well that's what it is
well listen I'm a big fan of Tucker and
I was telling him when he first launched
it like two years ago I go dude I'm
subscribed the things aren't loading
it's really he goes I know I mean he's
like I'm trying to make them in the
years why does he sound like Cobra
commands I know I tried that I was
talking to Tucker it's like the club
station does not function properly
inspectors and Scott
I'm here to tell you that if you don't
get it fixed I'll have you liquidated
yes and uh almost like we've experienced
this too sometimes where you're not in
control of the consumer experience and
you're pissed how dare you care about
your viewers I that to me I see that I
see a guy who's mad on behalf of his
viewers of course left us out list I've
been celebrating this as a huge stain on
Tucker The Daily Beast ran this headline
watch Tucker Carlson blast Fox Nation
behind the scene this site sucks here's
another one that they want you to think
is offensive and by the way what's
important is when you see so-called
conservatives uh use Media Matters as a
useful tool you know this it happens oh
you know Fox right now here's the deal
he has a non-disparagement clause he's
not doing it he's following the contract
Fox is leaking these videos he even says
it one of the videos I know it's been
recording the bird better not ever put
this out he's just joking around they're
back there in DC and New York recording
it and now they're leaking his text all
of it this is really nasty yeah well for
the same reason that's going to help
them when they lost half their viewers
right since he left
look I found out what really went on
with this but I'm a lot to talk about I
know a little bit okay well let's see
what we can talk about
I know something you don't know I saw I
leaned in okay hold on hold on I'm sure
is it Tucker related yes it is
do you want to say now or do you want to
do at the end of the segment I'll do
whatever you say
it's like Christmas morning
now to it all right
think about it take some time and then
I'd want and then just you know pull
that rip so here's the thing too uh we
have this rule here for example tool man
you know we never record run through no
thank God for you today yeah uh for the
same reason we always when we're filming
all the isos are recording in case you
have to go back and edit you know use
reaction like sometimes Alex does
something really funny that you miss on
camera but we don't record before and
because when you're doing run through
especially with comedy you need to have
the ability to go too far you know like
Alex showing me his balls but here's
another clip uh in which Tucker took aim
at Media Matters and of course this is
being leaked to leftist Outlets from
so-called conservative allies you
wouldn't okay I'm not you know what I'm
not qualified on that score I will say
I thought his girlfriend was kind of
yummy
just kidding just kidding cases being
pulled off the bird
yeah the bird hey Media Matters for
America go yourself that's the
first thing I want to say tonight second
thing is totally kidding I don't even
know what his girlfriend looks like and
if I did I would not find her yummy now
here's the thing
I met Tucker a few times and if ever you
heard me on the show people trying to
pull my only criticism was I said you
know he was this is kind of bow tie era
Tucker and I was like I don't know he
seemed like he was a nice guy but he
seemed a little stuffy this makes me
want to party with Dr Carlson he's super
cool I love it I only met him in the
Green Room at Fox back then before
nobody used to be real stuffy and but
about 11 12 years ago he called said hey
I'm sorry you're really right I messed
up I thought you were full of crap but I
mean I think you're actually pretty
smart that he wanted to come to Austin
ten years ago and we come pretty good
friends but now he's wild he's Unchained
and he is you know super awake to what's
uh really going on and pissed off and I
gotta say the fact that fox producers
that's who did this leaked this to Media
Matters and others
shows that they're stupid just like they
thought it wouldn't kill half Their
audience get rid of their you know top
show and now they're going to attack him
as if viewers and people aren't going to
know they did this so he kept his mouth
shut right he didn't say a word even on
the phone with me and in Texas he won't
talk crap about Fox right he just says
this is super dark stuff but I'm just
going to move forward but meanwhile
meanwhile I've talked to his producers
and people too he said no we're taking
the high road meanwhile they are
literally leaking crap on him as if they
think that'll make them look good to
people if they can burn Tucker meanwhile
they're so disconnected this is all
endearing well here's what they have to
do then right because what they go they
go oh I know what we'll do I know what
we'll do we have to make sure we turn
off with women so maybe not Media
Matters maybe not him saying the Fox
Nation sucks because we kind of
self-owned by leaking that clip but yeah
but they also caught Tucker Carlson
making fun uh of course denigrating
women which should never ever happen
well I feel great you know I could never
I can never assess my appearance I wait
for
my post-menopausal fans to weigh in on
that
so this has been labeled
[Music]
can be both hilarious and disastrous I
want to make a just a comment here
anyway have you ever seen a fight take
place with my dad and my mom I love you
mom but she had menopause
you just wait it out right that's it's
one of those things when a man says
women if you're watching just comment if
you understand this when a man asks hey
we're having a fight is it is it
potentially that that time of the month
that's that is an act of Mercy that's a
guy saying none of this is going to be
taken personally right I understand that
you might be emotional if there's
menopause there are things that are
outside of your control it's okay just
let me know so I can turtle for a little
bit and go for a drive
and then they come up and apologize
later my mom's sweetest person ever when
she went through menopause my dad would
just go for a drive and then later she'd
apologize right and here's the deal I'm
having a bad business day a bunch of
crazy stuff stressed out I got home at
like seven and my wife asked me to do
something I'll snap at her and then say
oh I'm sorry I had a bad day it's kind
of the same thing right but you love
each other overall and you and you got
to get thicker skins people teach each
other that oh it's all supposed to be
peaches and ice cream no the world is
stressful especially if you're actually
raising kids and working hard right and
but at the end of the day you love each
other and you apologize to each other
when it happens but because that's what
they say about you they say he works
hard for the money absolutely but look
the truth is he had the top demographics
in uh women 45 and up and so he was
saying I never know how I look to my
main demographic post by the Muslim
women so it's somewhat of a joke but
it's endearing joke for crying out loud
you know how many women period watch
Tucker Carlson and sit there and you
know on their period he said period no
so uh here's the biggest revelation of
Tucker no I don't care that was not a
pun so yeah the thing right now they
want they want to blame you by leaking
his texts and would anyone's life stand
up to every single one of your texts and
one of your phone calls and Camera
moments being revealed not a single one
of you and anyone who says it was lying
and by the way I'm shocked that this is
what they're leaking on Tucker this is
they're making him look amazing oh for
crying what they could have done from
just run through this morning yeah
including yourself Gerald which is not
true which surprised me and would
surprise our Jewish intern that is not
what happened slavery was okay no it
wasn't here's the thing they leaked this
text and it's supposed to be this big
Revelation but I don't think it actually
uh tells you what they think it tells
you and so I don't really take a Carl's
impression the closest I have is the bow
tie because I miss the bow tie all right
nice there it is so I'm going to read
you the text in its entire entirety it
says a couple of weeks ago I was
watching video of people fighting on the
street in Washington a group of trump
guys surrounded an ant of a kid and
started pounding the living out of
him it was three against one at least
jumping a guy like that is dishonorable
obviously it's not how white men fight
yet some way I found myself rooting for
the mob against the man hoping they'd
hit him harder kill him I really wanted
them to hurt the kid I could taste it
then somewhere deep in my brain an alarm
went off this isn't good for me I'm
becoming something I don't want to be
the antifa creep is a human being much
as I despise what he says and does much
as I sure I would hate him personally if
I knew him I shouldn't gloat over his
suffering I should be bothered by it I
should remember that somewhere somebody
probably loves this kid and will be
crushed if he was killed I don't care
about those things if I reduce people to
their politics how am I better than he
is comment if you think that's the
fight-ending bomb against Tucker Carlson
no it's it's totally true and let's just
be honest on average going back to
Western chivalry and Duels with swords
and guns and all the rest of it you
could go out and fight another man of
the death as long as you didn't jump him
and as long as it was Mutual you know
bringing outside the air of the duel
ended about 150 years ago in the wild
wild west where two men would face off
in the square and then you know pull
their guns and shoot each other so it
really is a western thing to not gang up
on somebody it does happen but it's
looked down on right but it is true that
you know 50 to 1 because that goes on a
lot we see these videos every day of
racist black youth and that's not all
black people it's a minority of them
gang up on white people and beating them
many times to death World Star Hip-Hop
you know made makes its money showing
this stuff so the idea of what he's
saying is is that you know this is not
something under Western chivalry we're
supposed to do and I need to humanize
antifa even though what they do is gang
up and Bully and attack people and by
the way one thing to be certain of
there's going there's going to be worse
this is what they're going to They're
Gonna Leave This and then so that that
way people defend them and then they
have something worse then they have
something that for him people say is
more embarrassing or alienates them just
understand what's happening and look I'm
not like with you and yet there were a
lot of people who didn't give you any
backup and you and I weren't even very
close friends I felt compelled to do so
look no one's life stands up to this
kind of script I know that Tucker
Carlson's in for a rough go but this is
just dirty but it also shows an
evolution with with his thinking yes
it's a Redemption Arc it's like telling
the Scrooge story without the fact that
through his revelatory uh Reformation
through Christ by the way it's basically
like the Fifth Gospel if you haven't
read A Christmas Carol he kept Christmas
heart it in his heart and kept it well
as well as anyone ever has that's the
Redemption here he's saying I realized
that I was wrong yeah exactly it's like
showing a clip of him Ebenezer Scrooge
at the beginning and saying see he's an
a-hole and it's like well you didn't
show the end yes he had that's a perfect
that's a Perfect Analogy where he's
taking care of Tiny Tim and no one kept
Christmas as well as Ebenezer Scrooge
and he became a conservative by the way
at first he said are there no prisons
are there no poor houses he said my tax
dollars go there so they should seek out
help there decrease the Surplus
population then at the end he decided
that personal charity was more important
and he kept it you have an idea how
expensive it would be to keep Tiny Tim
alive I don't know if he had Polio if he
had rickets it was before Modern Health
Insurance absolutely and so look I I
know what went on with I'm gonna
leave it at that and I don't know come
on I mean I'm going to say a little bit
okay well go ahead okay well number one
there's a non-disparagement contract of
course he said nothing negative about
him correct to anybody right uh and
I'm just gonna leave it at this
[Applause]
yes it was a composite of reasons he was
against the war in Ukraine he was
against the open borders he was exposing
Hunter Biden he was exposing the Central
Bank digital currencies January 6th but
I I was told by sources very close to
Tucker only but this that the Vanity
Fair article is the closest to reality
he was about a month and a half ago
about five weeks ago he was in Bel Air
at the big mansion estate of river
Murdoch and his fiancee who is a big fan
of Tucker and has become religious and
Christian because of Tucker and she
thinks he's like a prophet Tucker has
become very Christian before he was kind
of agnostic raised Episcopalian right
wasn't sure God was real but like
Christians and thought they were good
for society but he really just you know
still thought it was kind of silly then
uh he's had experiences seeing things
grown and at some point I'm sure he'll
talk about the details of it but had
some really interesting experiences uh
kind of saw on the road solid Targets on
the road to Damascus things to where he
really knows it's a fight between good
versus evil he's been saying that and
Rue Murdoch is an atheist he got really
freaked out uh wouldn't talk basically
left in her table he was quote friends
with Tucker before that uh and then the
next day broke up with his girlfriend
and said I'm done with you his fiancee
get out of here and so what whatever
went up that dinner and and I don't know
all the details I was just told no
Vanity Fair is the tip of the iceberg
that's what it is and so Tucker is
extremely uh trying to be screaming
close to God you call it born again but
not even in church all the spiritual
Awakenings and then a conflict of
conscience perhaps yes yeah and by the
way you and I have talked about that you
and I weren't very clear you were more I
don't want to say in the conspiracy
theory but you didn't talk about your
faith as much back in the day and you
and I kind of came closer when I
realized a good portion of what you said
was right and then you also sort of said
that your faith became more of a
priority to you and I kind of came
closer in our viewpoints that's a that's
a very real experience absolutely well I
mean I was raised Christian Evangelical
Baptist and I believe in God uh you know
had a holy ghost experience when I was
about 10 years old except Jesus Christ
my Lord and Savior but then I kind of
became corrupt not like evil but bad and
out of control and tons of sex and
fights and wildness until I was about 17
humble break and and then well
is that until you were about 17. geez I
actually wish I had done all that no
it's pretty wild but I mean I was
looking five years older than I was but
the point is is that I grew up fast grow
up mean and the and my fish got hard my
you know all the rest is uh yeah let's
let's be careful yeah but no no I but
then I know that if you and I have had
conversations process of watching all
this evil and things I started having
about six seven years ago a lot more
religious experiences uh spiritual
experiences and just could see the evil
in the world and just felt the Holy
Spirit even stronger and had a bunch of
other experiences that just made it
completely clear to where it my faith
became stronger than ever was and so
it's been and then I finally got
attacked more absolutely the minute I
started saying Jesus Christ on the air
that my Lord and Savior is Jesus Christ
and that uh people telling people you
really shouldn't have sex for marriage
and yeah it's very destructive I've been
there and let me guess a lot of the
attacks were saying you weren't a real
Christian when you actually were
becoming one yes exactly that's exactly
said oh you admit that you were involved
in abortions when you were like 17. you
admit you did bad I said well yes I said
I admit I did bad things and I Repent of
it now I didn't understand it was bad
then but but that's what the world acts
like no Christ is there we actually see
Christ's faith and face and repent to to
to forgive us that that's and it really
happened and you get rid of the old
person and then comes the new doesn't
mean I'm perfect now but a lot better
than it was good for you Paul that was
it that hey that's a clip you sons of
back there and I know he just
talked about Chris and I said sons of
you guys I don't care Media
Matters have your moment shut up Gerald
David killed a lot of people my point is
you need both lambs and lions and this
man is a lion and I at one point I just
didn't know what to make of Alex
remember we were doing a change my mind
in Austin he came out he said Stephen
Crowder raped me and I was like what is
what is this guy doing and then I
realized after you were just screwing
around but you have to understand some
people thought that I actually raped you
all right so let's go on now to troops
to the Border this is a big story and
Alex has a show that he will not be
getting to so uh we'll begin the Mud
Club and of course keep it on on time
today for the first time at mad
maxworld.tv it doesn't exist so at the
border
things are deteriorating right at
alarming rates yeah but here's the issue
that I want to draw your attention to
it's not okay uh what is the truth what
is the truth and contrast it with what
you were told the truth was not too long
ago when it's the same person and
they're not saying I changed my mind
they're trying to memory hole it so this
brings us to now what is happening on
the border
Tuesday all the references are available
at lottery.com uh the Biden
Administration former Vice President
Biden announced that it would be sending
uh 1500 active duty troops to the
southern border
land security secretary Austin approved
a temporary Department of Defense
increase of an additional 1500 military
personnel to supplement U.S Customs and
Border Protection efforts on the U.S
Southwest border for 90 days these 1500
military personnel who will be sourced
from the active duty is it the Michael J
fox camera operating critical capability
gaps such as ground-based detection and
monitoring data entry
and Warehouse support until cpv can
address these needs through contracted
so really quick context by the way the
announcement comes as a Title II is set
to expire and Joe you know that was uh
battle 42 yes what did I say 92 you said
two oh there's 40 other titles yes
exactly there's 44 title 42 so take that
my first number
add 40 more title 42 uh is the title
that allowed up government uh the
government to expel migrants at the
grounds of Public Health right it was a
revolving door that Donald Trump
installed that threw you back into
Mexico right yes exactly it was like
especially an accelerated deportation
yeah yes it was like elf with ponchos
oh no I'm back here now so
they're saying now we're sending troops
to the border now regardless of of where
you line up as to whether that's a good
idea or a bad idea and I understand the
conversation we had we need to secure
the Border but I also understand the
concern but I know what's really going
on well hold on I know you do of course
spoiler alert Alex knows what's really
going on uh this is them now but this is
back then in 2018 the bite
Administration said that the military
border deployments were quote
inappropriate according to Kamala Harris
who also uh happened to be going through
menopause I believe that it is
inappropriate we require the limited
resources of the United States military
to be used in such a way and all because
there needed to be some demonstration
for the TV cameras based on a political
agenda instead of what is a national
security threat ah and now 1500 troops
deployed again what matters is is the
law ever applied consistently look when
you have people like Alex Jones
pretty consistent in the fact that we
need to be a nation of borders people on
left it depends on what the voting
demographic is it depends on what the
and there's a lot going on by the way uh
down at the border so we will get to in
a second but first like the show you
know especially if you're okay with a
little bit of talk of uh you know uh
Jesus Christ Lord and Savior Alex Jones
just to just hit me right in the fields
if you like like the show share it with
your friends but right now because he is
there we have to go to Thomas Finnegan
our on the ground correspondent at the
border
[Music]
thank you all right Mr Finnegan uh if
you can hear me what are you seeing down
there at the border sir hi Stephen I'm
almost there
uh
give me a few seconds and I'll be on the
ground to give you the scoop you're up
why are you so late why are you getting
there now Finnegan I had to stop and uh
I mean I had to make uh you had to take
a dump didn't you this is not the first
time you just take a dump Finn again
yeah if you want to put it that way okay
I did put it that way fine take all the
time in the world you need during this
live show that's enough that's
enoughless
[Music]
all right Alex I want to go to you at
the end of this because I know you're
going to take the you know what's really
going on but I see a report on what the
news is saying is going on first so
situation on the ground is already so
bad and not saying that you're not
losing at their news no I agree with you
fake news but so what fake news is
saying is going on because even fake
news CNN is acknowledging because
sometimes you're fancy like what are you
saying he's fake no no I'm saying I'm
saying he's right but the people you're
about to watch are so CNN is
even taking notice uh here they were
either this morning or last night
it's difficult to describe Jim with
words
you can walk with me and just see the
magnitude of the nurse of individuals
who are around this church here just
just streets from downtown
a lot of these individuals you'll see
are males adult males a lot of them are
actually in shelters and a network of
shelters throughout El Paso as you
mentioned the city of El Paso under a
state of emergency they declared a
disaster because El Paso On the Border
that once title 42 lifts that there is
going to be a greater influx of migrants
but here's the thing so process this
with me title 42 allows immigration
agents to swiftly back to Mexico so the
obvious question as you look around is
then why are there so many migrants if
the federal government is actually
implementing this title 42. hold on a
second she was asking a question let's
hope she doesn't just pull a Jesse
Venture like I'm just asking questions
let's let the esteemed Shawshank
reporter okay fine let's see it and
finish that's fair from talking to
migrants and Community leaders and
officials on both sides of the Border I
can tell you that thousands of migrants
nearly 40 000 are in at least four
Northern Mexican cities and frustration
is awkward shots
that's why you see so many out here some
of them are turning them to border
authorities Jim others are deciding to
cross the border illegally because
they've lost patience
this is Legacy me just sit you see that
shot he's literally
I don't know they're paying me scale so
let's go through some of the claims and
the truths and then of course some more
commentary from Alex so here's the claim
right now uh from Karen jump yeah and
all references are available
Karen she she says that illegal
immigration is down ninety percent said
yesterday that when it comes to Illegal
migration you've seen it come down by
more than 90 percent where did that
number come from it was I was speaking
he was telling us the number is I hear
you I'm about to answer I'm about to
people
if you if The Dramatics could come down
just a little bit but The Dramatics will
come down a little bit dramatic
asking a question about okay I'm gonna
answer so I was speaking to the parolee
program
to deal with uh to deal with certain
countries uh on on ways that we can
limit illegal migration and we have seen
the data has shown what's gone down by
more than 90 that was
wouldn't you love it if you just said
okay sweetheart down with The Dramatics
right
she's clearly want to be more dramatic
this is the issue is what they do is
hold on okay so that's what she claimed
down 90 here's the truth
truth there are two women border
crossings
in March this is the last month of data
that we have up 26 from January lows
that's 162
000 total Crossing so and his point was
actually very good it was up 120 or 130
000 for the year that's a lot of people
26 from January now let me tell you
where she gets these numbers the 90
figure and this is the issue right
there's lies damn lies and statistics
sometimes they're relevant but if it's
coming from the White House Press
Secretary
so
I'm a child in March apprehensions from
these specific four countries only we're
down 95 Venezuela Nicaragua Cuba Haiti
all places of cigars except for
Venezuela and Haiti but Venezuela lots
of Miss Universe winners so you know
what I'm a fan this
95 decrease
there was a parole parole program a
Venezuelan parole program which just so
happened to be extended to guess the
countries guess the countries Gerald uh
Nicaragua Cuba Haiti
go ding ding so those four countries
it's down 95 but that doesn't make the
overall number is up and let me just
read you a quote this is you can go and
read uh you can read the extension
yourself as extended it allows 30 000
Nationals of those countries to enter
the United States per month with work oh
sorry with work authorization on parole
for a two-year period in lieu of
entering wait wait so they just
legalized them all from those countries
and said oh look now it's down because
they're not we're not calling them
illegal even though if you have that
number it's even up more and that's what
I was going to get to of what's really
going on here I'm sorry that I cut you
well does that that's a good thing we're
we're synergistic yes no no no but
absolutely I've been down on the border
a month I didn't know if you were pissed
off because it's not about her oh okay
you're too nice seriously okay good
here's what's really going on we've
talked to high-level federal agents
we've talked to I'm not going to say I
mean let's just say people high up in
the Judiciary
just recently about what's really going
on they are being told
they bore Patrol in ice to fake the
numbers in the two last two and a half
years with Biden they're losing upwards
of 80 of people because they just walk
right through the numbers are so big
right 2 000 people there in like 20
yards so and that's an important fact
the numbers that we're getting are by
the way the most conservative estimates
humanly possible that's right so they
estimate it's about 80 percent get away
and here's what's really happening when
when Trump sent troops to the Border
that's because he was turning back about
98 of people using title 42. when Biden
puts troops on the border that's because
the border patrol is so overwhelmed they
can't even get the crowds processed to
get them on buses and planes to fly them
to Blue cities that's why the New York
mayor of the Chicago mayor complaining
is because literally they're just
illegals standing around everywhere like
you saw in that clip on CNN but in
Dallas in Chicago in Detroit in New York
in Miami but also in the panhandle of
Florida California Austin Texas they're
just everywhere anywhere planes trained
snow Caminos exactly
so the numbers we hear that are record
and she lies and says they're down 90
using a manipulation about another
program you know that's that that's a
shell game are up hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of percent so it was Obama
that said if you're a child you can just
be let in so then suddenly 25 year old
men with mustaches were being let in yes
then Trump clamped it down and cut it
back 90 plus percent under Biden talked
to the border patrol they said it's
about four times worse than it was under
Obama they estimate wow that John just
last year eight million illegals came
across in the Texas sector and by the
way a lot of people don't know this when
Barack Obama instituted uh or extended
that we're not we're not talking about
the Florida's consent policy that was
where they couldn't be held uh
separately but when he said if you're a
child you can come here um a lot of
people don't know the sales of propeller
hats went up four thousand percent
so uh but let me have one more big
tidbit yeah this has all been confessed
to remember what happened uh I'm sorry
Gerald you're not getting a word in
edgewise today remember what happened to
jump in on Gerald remember no no no
remember three years ago right during
the middle of the campaign Biden said
multiple times if I am elected
immediately surge the Border Asylum
Seekers and we'll get you in that's your
right so they had sometimes Caravans
wearing Joe Biden shirts yep uh coming
in and the same un NGO that in the last
15 years ran the invasion of Europe that
guy runs the Texas sector because an NGO
is above the border patrol when you go
there and there's these giant tent city
facilities the size of like five
football fields up to give me tens of
thousands it's insane you got to see it
for yourself it really is giant in giant
air conditioning trucks just huge
cafeterias it he
it's like an army invading and you see
the literal blue and green haired NGO
people walking around through the fence
ordering the troops and ordering the the
border patrol around so this is all run
by Biden he said come here it's open so
the troops aren't being sent to turn
them back he's getting rid of title 42
right he's already by Fiat gotten rid of
it that's why the senior reporters are
saying if title 42 is here why would
they have been sent back because they're
not enforcing title 42. very important
including on top of convicted pedophiles
yeah that's an important distinction to
made to make a lot of people more slaves
than ever in recorded history over 40
million and a huge portion of them are
sex slaves although that somehow makes
it better nope nope sex slaves kind of
worse than I mean slavery's bad but
worse sex here's the thing slavery is
bad I want to be careful with my words
very clear slavery is bad very bad I
would argue it's worse when you add sex
so uh just my opinion that's me Mr
traditional and actually we're getting
word right now that uh oh Thomas
Finnegan has actually he's finally
arrived at the border let's see what he
has for us
[Music]
all right Thomas what's the situation
now that you're at the border okay
Stephen
I'm happy to report that I'm at the
border everything is coming peaceful and
I made good time Finnegan it's clearly
the wrong border that's Canada I don't
understand I Flip Flip the
printed the direction yeah Finnegan Flip
Flip the paper around
turn it
oh
[Music]
all right so I have a difficult balance
to match here by the way lottery.com mug
club like we said is it free mug Club at
ladder with crowder.com yes enter in
your proof of any subscription service
including the one well you know Tucker
Carlson says a lot of them suck so enter
in your screenshot and you get ours free
for three months uh I know we want to
talk about the Santa's killing
pedophiles we also have the book Banning
thing but Alex Jones is here with us of
course and he will not be streaming Mad
Max world uh dot TV afterwards you
wanted to talk about because it just
broke when we were getting ready here
this morning uh Putin and the drone
strikes do you want to hit on that now
or I mean if we can do it really quickly
absolutely well you're still on top of
things we were talking with your
producers last night what we're going to
cover this morning at 7 A.M and I'm just
kind of like hey I know all this stuff
is important I agree but two drones
slammed into the residential complex at
the Kremlin
in Moscow today launched probably from
inside Russia uh Ukraine has been
bragging and I guess taking
responsibility for it and now they're
saying maybe they didn't do it could it
be a false flag uh I don't know I mean I
wouldn't put that you know uh above the
Russians but the ukrainians have said
we'll start striking inside Russia
they've been striking inside Russia
they've been striking uh into the
suburbs of Moscow they've been car
bombing a lot of journalists and other
people and they've launched their quote
new spring offensive uh and they're
threatening to even go into Russia and
quote Park tanks in red square and so
the Russians are saying Wonder our
Doctrine that's a red line show they
they they they said just a few months
ago if you try to kill Putin that's an
act of war and we will consider using
nuclear weapons so right things are
escalating very very quickly yeah so the
consequences could be very severe
wherever you line up by the way you can
also have what are you telling me hoodie
so we got the video we have two videos
and also a statement from the Kremlin
the video of the strike yeah yeah of the
actual okay well hold on a second by the
way if you guys are watching right now
on YouTube and you see and hear this
yeah it means head on over to rumble
because you know they're not even and
this is not a pro-russia narrative at
all we're just letting you know as this
unfolds but if you say anything that
isn't radically pro-ukraine on YouTube
right in every facet as far as I'm
concerned neither one of these countries
they're both incredibly corrupt it's a
Slavic Civil War
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that was my skull dude all right let's
go radical man fantastic let's go
[Music]
thank you
I don't know about I think this is good
news to celebrate right some actual some
good news here Monday yeah God Russia
signed no no this is really good news
story signed a bill that's going to
allow the death penalty for child
rapists
no you're gonna get banned on YouTube
for that no make up school teachers and
give the children to them I was hoping
for a musical components broke hey the
U.S the UN just passed a regulation that
children can have sex oh I know we
talked about that are you against the
U.N yes you're a bigot I know
you're a bigot I know listen I want you
man right now that should be banned on
YouTube oh you've already done your damn
distance so
supporting the death penalty which by
the way
[Music]
years of these crimes are oftentimes
serial offenders and if someone does uh
one if they if they rape a child uh like
and these are very young very young
children sometimes like six seven eight
years old if they do that once chances
are they will do it again unless they're
stopped unless they're incapacitated and
so we really believe that part of a just
Society is to have appropriate
punishment and so if you commit a crime
that is um
foreign
[Music]
files as high as 30 or 40 percent right
that's a conservative estimate you can
bring this up it's overlay surgery from
Leadership Council uh and and
[Music]
thank you
for spectral battery of a child Under 12
years old so just to be clear like I've
said this in the past I don't think that
you should lump just like Aziz Ansari as
much as I don't like them or Chris Chris
was a Hardwick shouldn't be lumped in
with someone like someone like a Bill
Cosby or someone like a Roman Polanski
right so you've had guys who are 18 they
sleep with their 17 year old girlfriend
they go to jail for life this is very
clear this is about sexual battery for
children under 12 years sexual assault
sexual yeah sexual well yeah exactly for
children under 12. we have a very very
specific line here the law goes against
a 2008 Supreme Court ruling that would
prevent rapists from receiving the death
penalty without the death of the child
no no I should have been sarcastic
earlier on such a serious uh issue but I
think this is good
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
not ready for you they're planning it
when you came in uh all right we have uh
should we start this here before yeah we
should start before we go to month club
because again Alex is not going to be
Alex Jones at mad maxworld.tv and so he
has a show to do after this but of
course we will be going to mug Club I
think we should start probably right now
yeah because this this
has been also he's been lambasting in
the media for Banning books in Florida
right right so that was one of the
things that people were saying oh this
guy I can't believe he's Banning books
and it's like well let's look at the
content let's look at the context
because they try and say oh
conservatives want to ban books and uh
no hold on a second let's look at the
books that people think are age
inappropriate just to be clear they're
not Banning these books for adults
they're banning these books to be taught
to children or in places where children
are often mandated to spend time as part
of the curriculum so let me set this up
for you really quickly uh according to
the American Library Association 2022
had the highest number of attempted book
bands uh since they began compiling data
about censor I don't know why it just
sounded like from Chicago sounded like
Dennis since they began compiling data
I'm gonna stab this pencil stick right
in your eye
uh the most challenged book on the list
that the right was trying to censor was
the book genderqueer
foreign
[Music]
fine for contrast to the left they
wanted a band To Kill a Mockingbird
because it was racist I don't look I
don't know if you're familiar with the
story of To Kill a Mockingbird one could
almost argue that it had an anti-racist
message I know I know Just Go With It
was obviously a super uh civil rights
anti-racist message for the heroes of
course are are fighting the races but
again they want control listen how many
hundreds of books are they now rewriting
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
everything because people are called fat
in it they're the ones not just Banning
books but irrevocably mutilating them
and vandalizing them and memory holding
them from 1984 in the ministry of Truth
all we're saying is don't give graphic
Pro pedophilia pedophile books to middle
schoolers and high
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
might actually be something that this is
going to hurt at first but it'll get
better exactly that's exactly I mean we
saw The Lovely Bones always be polite
that's the first rule We Know How It
Ends look we're going to continue
discussing this because there's no way
they'll allow it on YouTube because so
many people there are pro groomers and
thank you so much trouble but right now
if you're watching on Rumble okay if
you're watching on YouTube go to
atlanta.com you get three months free
right we told you about that proof of
any membership if you're watching on
Rumble right now just go click that
button that button right down there
click and you get to keep watching for
another 45 minutes to an hour probably
45 minutes because Alex Jones has
another show to make thank you so much
oh